a major standoff over the border is
underway right now Texas trading barbs
with the federal government over literal
barbs and Democrats now want Joe Biden
to seize Texas troops to sort it all out
Governor Greg Abbot pledging to wrap the
border with more razor wire after the
Supreme Court gave Biden the go-ahead to
remove it Abbott argues it's his State's
right to install more of the prickly
barriers even wrote Joe a long letter
about it where he accused him of
violating his oath
the Biden Administration has really
truly abdicated its responsibility to
secure the border and inforce the laws
Texas very simply is securing the border
and so we put up the razor wire that you
were talking about Bill and we put up
all these barricades that actually have
denied illegal entry and as you pointed
out also in that screening that there
are criminals coming across our border
Texas has a right as a state to stop
crimin criminals from coming into our
state what Texas is doing is what
Americans expect to be done so far at
least 17 Republican Governors are
backing Abbott's right to self-defense
and how's this for malarkey the same
White House that smeared border patrol
agents as whipping crazed lunatics is
all of a sudden concerned that Greg
Abbott is putting them In Harm's Way we
have been very clear we want to make
sure we get something done at the border
that's why we've been having these
conversation with Senate Republicans and
democrats for the past several weeks to
come up with a bipartisan agreement to
deal with the Border Governor Abbott is
not interested in that he wants to
politicize an issue and he's not helping
communities he actually isn't and he's
actually putting border patrol agents In
Harm's Way by doing what he's
doing the standoff is a real mess and
sadly our fearless borders are Kamala
hasn't been able to find a
solution sadly it has become so deeply
partisan
and the subject of them political
gamesmanship when in fact the solutions
are at hand and we offered a solution
early on and invited bipartisan work
let's work on it to fix this but sadly I
you know we want to fix it they want to
run on it they want to they want a
political issue to run on in
November all right Dana this is
interesting so the Supreme Court
basically said that the feds can take
down the razor wire but Texas can put it
back up yeah they didn't say Texas did
anything wrong yeah um but what they the
Supreme Court did without actually
giving much of an explanation which is I
think a little bit part of the confusion
and might have been a good idea to like
write three paragraphs as to what they
were thinking so it goes back to the
appeals court and then I think
eventually it does get to the Supreme
Court I think it's now up to 24 states
that are supporting Abbott so this comes
down to a question that was really
fundamental to the founding of the
country the reason that all the states
got together is say yes we'll form a
union is because the federal government
said that it would protect the states
and that if it wasn't going to do that
for some reason because it didn't want
to or couldn't that you could them
protect yourself so this could really
get to the Supreme Court and be very
good um I don't think there's a big
concern that all of a sudden the Biden
Administration wants a picture of
sending in a bunch of feds in order to
try to deal with this because guess what
they haven't done that for the last
three years why would why start now and
I do think that when KLA Harris says
that the Republicans just want a
political issue
this is this has been going back and
forth for a couple of decades in 2007
Harry Reid remember that guy the late
Harry Reid on the Democratic side they
did the same thing they said we don't
want to have a immigration Bel it was
much farther along and really was
basically said that we want Hillary or
Obama to be able to run on this issue
and then look what happened nothing ever
got solved exactly Jesse yes good to see
you as always welcome back to the show
it's good to be back around the table oh
well I'm you know I already said that to
you you know um Jesse you you just heard
kamla Harris tell us that she had a
solution where was the solution remember
it was all about root causes which
included her incompetence right so the
Republicans in the house passed a border
security Bill last year and it died
under Chuck
Schumer they said they didn't want to
touch it because it didn't address root
causes yeah it did MH imagine Greg
Russians just start pouring over the
bearing straight into Alaska and the
federal government just processed them
into the state and wouldn't let Alaska
repel them or the Chinese started coming
in on their vessels into Hawaii and the
federal government just started
processing the Chinese thousands of them
day after day and they started filling
up Hawaii and Hawaii couldn't defend
itself that's crazy it is absolutely
crazy Texas has declared this an
invasion now the polling shows the
majority of the American people believe
it's invasion
and if you look at legal precedent it
says the Supreme Court has said that the
states have the right to use Force to
repel an invasion they're saying this
isn't a violent Invasion okay what about
the drugs the human and the sex
trafficking that comes along with this
now the Democrats have already said what
their goal is KLA Harris just said it
yesterday the goal is to process more
migrants and give them a faster Pathway
to citizenship Jerry Nadler said they
want to bring them in so they can pick
crops and have babies the Castro
Brothers said they want to turn Texas
blue the other Democrat said they want
to boost the migrant population in her
District because the census counts
illegals so it gives them a boost in
representation Biden has shredded since
day one every single thing Donald Trump
put there he stopped deportations he
stopped the wall and started handing out
bus tickets and turned the border of
Patrol agents into a Turn Style so
if you're going to get catch a guy 40
times a trafficker for a cartel and
release him 40 times he's caught and
released you don't want to stop the
Border crisis now California's paying
for sex changes for illegal aliens Juan
comes in goes to California becomes
Wanita we get the bill that is absolute
insanity and I will not tolerate it I
don't know if that's bad you want want
to pay for it ition judge you're doing
all right judge hypothetically civil war
is coming it's coming we have 24 States
on Texas's side that leaves
26 no that's 60 is that 50 yeah 26 that
was an English major so who side would
you go on I I mean like take a guess yes
I think I would have to fight for Texas
right yes yes look Texas is defending
itself from lawlessness and what has
happened in the Supreme Court was a that
there was a move to vacate the
injunction that case has not yet been
decided in terms of the substance of the
case that it's only a procedural thing
where they have to take the razor wire
down the case it's not decided look the
Biden Administration is complicit in
aiding and abetting the invasion of this
country by Uninvited unvetted illegal
immigrants that's the that's the that's
the the headline here to prove it they
have fought every state action to where
Governors have tried to protect their
estate from illegals whether it's Texas
and the water the buoys in the Water
Texas and the razor wire over the river
or whether it was Arizona that tried to
build the wall and to prove that they
are complicit with this invasion they
moved all the way to the United States
Supreme Court to stop the enforcement of
article 42 of title 42 which required a
Slowdown at the border they didn't want
that and while Americans First
Responders nurses doctors uh uh veteran
cops they all had to be vaccinated the
illegals not only were never tested they
were allowed in during an international
pandemic and they were never required to
have a vaccine all the immigrants enter
this country and they are allowed to
just enter there's no remain in Mexico
and what the Biden Administration did
was they they allowed millions of
dollars in construction property that
was ready to build the wall to be stolen
or scavenged at the border and finally
on top of the actions they did this
Administration what criminals do they
lied Joe Biden lied Karine jeanpierre
lied mayorcas lied to Congress openly
and Biden never said I will not allow my
Secretary of Homeland Security to lie to
the American people and say that the
border is is secure because it's not he
not only allows Biden to lie but they
lied about whip gate never took it back
they lied about the razor wire saying we
needed to protect the illegals in case
case they drowned then we find out they
drowned an hour before they border of
Patrol even knew about it so this bill
this bill that they're talking about
when the Democrats had the house the
Senate and the oval and they could have
solved this themselves what they want to
do now is they want to allow 5,000
people in a day that's 150,000 people a
month when the highest number When
Donald Trump was there was 70,000 they
want to double it I don't want to pay
for them I don't want them in my school
I don't want my hospitals to go bankrupt
because of this Jessica I was so
pleasantly surprised in the green room
when you came up to me and you said you
know who saw this coming Donald Trump if
only we had listened to him about the
wall we could have avoided this mess and
I thought wow Jessica that was amazing
every time you share a private
conversations a little bit of my heart
breaks um I'm mostly wondering if I can
get the same research as Jesse so I can
get those Nadler quotes about picking
crops and making babies you haven't seen
Jesse water prime time Jessica how dare
you I'm tending to my child between days
so um I'm going to surprise you a little
but then I'll revert to form so the
surprise
is that the Republicans and specifically
Greg Abbott and Ronda santis they a
thesis that busing migrants to Liberal
cities has worked out for them remember
there was a good amount of outrage
certainly and even some moderat thought
that the Martha's Vineyard thing was a
stun and it was bad but now that it has
turned into hundreds of thousands of
people you have liberals on the sides of
this who are at least saying this is a
huge crisis we have to deal with it
don't worry guys I'm back so the
bipartisan deal that has now been
scuttled because Donald Trump called up
Mitch McConnell and said hey I noticed
in Iowa and New Hampshire that uh
immigration is the number one issue and
I can't run on the economy anymore
because it's going gang busters I just
want to Larry cudow want to shout you
out so
3.3% growth for Q4 cudow said today
mostly government spending come on
Jessica uh economic advisor to Donald
Trump Larry cudow and a fox business
employee Biden gets his due if I were
him I would be out slinging that hash
too and it is it's really cheap to say
it's government spending they're
spending our money to to yeah to raise
interest I mean I'll be done so much
faster if you just let me go okay so I
wish popat
Puck reported that Mitch McConnell told
the Senate Republican conference Donald
Trump wants to run on this the politics
have change and I don't want to
undermine him Mitt Romney was in the
hallway this afternoon with a gaggle
talking to CNN I believe confirming this
and then someone uh Senator Tillis
talking about how he didn't come to the
Senate to cow toow to a president let
alone a former president who is now a
candidate he wants to pass good solid
policy this is where if Democrats can
talk about it properly and they
certainly should and they should be up
big uping this bipartisan deal which is
what includes the Ukraine funding and
the Israel funding and it does make it
harder for migrants to claim Asylum and
having that failsafe mechanism to
prevent more Jessica what if you didn't
want Trump to run on this why didn't you
solve the damn problem three years ago
to come back and go like oh my God
they're not solving this problem because
they want to run on it you guys have
been playing politics with this longer
than anybody you had the house of Senate
and the oval for years like 50 timeso
not no one wants you you're not BL
because he's not forcing the enforcing
the law all he needs to do is enforce
the law and that's the end of it no no
need to yell no one actually wants to
solve the illegal immigration problem on
either side because everyone I I don't
believe
you well you know that a little part of
my heart just broke I'm fine with it I
do have a heart I think everyone I'm
Brian kilme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now